la policía financiera de Francia allá no
hoy los locales del comité que organiza
los Juegos Olímpicos de París 2024 pero
también de solideo la empresa pública
encargada de entregar las licitaciones
de los distintos trabajos y obras de las
instalaciones que serán ocupadas en
estos juegos olímpicos estas
investigaciones y este allanamiento está
autorizado por dos justamente
investigaciones que lleva la policía
financiera una del año 2017 y otra del
año 2021 en que sospecha ambas
instituciones de conflicto de interés de
desvío de fondos públicos favoritismo y
sospecha de favoritismo no es el único
escándalo que rodea estos Juegos
Olímpicos en mayo renunció la presidenta
del comité olímpico o francés por luchas
y guerras internas y hoy también diez
trabajadores extranjeros pero legalmente
instalados en Francia que trabajan en
las obras de los Juegos Olímpicos
denunciaron ante la inspección del
trabajo a los grandes grupos de la
construcción por malas condiciones de
trabajo y presión Ellos dicen París no
es mejor que Qatar En referencia al
organizador del mundial
2022 ya desde comienzos de año hemos
escuchado las voces de varios
trabajadores inmigrantes sin
documentación en Francia que se quejan
de las condiciones de trabajo y de las
presiones sufridas por parte de estos
empresarios